A liberal arts education basically
just means that you have the opportunity
to explore
a bunch of different disciplines
and kind of find what fits you the best.
My own world arts
experience has allowed me to explore
topics that I like
that are really different.
I've taken cellular biology classes,
I've taken
Japanese language classes,
I've taken history classes.
Two weeks
after I got here, decided I want to do
molecular biology and biochemistry.
A month later decided that wasn't me.
And then at the end of my sophomore year,
ended up taking a psychology
class, discovering
I really like psychology.
I decided to do psychology
with a concentration in neuroscience.
The opportunity
to take things alongside art
has really fulfilled my need to explore.
I was able to take
so many different classes my first year
alone, and through that was able
to discover what I want to do.
That's really the whole approach
to education here at Yale,
is that, you know,
you have the freedom to explore
all different majors and opportunities
and academic programs that we offer
to figure out
what the best fit for you is.